hi in this video we're going to look at
carnitine shuttle system as the name
suggests this is a shuttle system that
means it is used to transport some
molecules and we would learn about that
we would learn about that where this
system is located what is the function
of this system and why it is at all
important in a physiological context in
order to understand that we have to
understand fasted and fade state our
body goes through fade and fasted state
and accordingly our metabolism changes
because in the failed state fatty absent
anabolism is preferred whereas in the
fasted State fatty acid catabolism need
to be triggered to generate further
energy now in the fasted State the
resolve of the fatty acid is that it
boosts tissue in adipose tissue
triglyceride would be broken down to
release free fatty acids and the free
fatty acid would be transported into the
hepatocytes inside the liver hepatocytes
the mitochondria of the liver
hepatocytes would carry out beta
oxidation of fatty acid and thereby
generating a stay away from that that
acetyl co a can be channeled into ketone
body biogenesis or can be used to
generate energy so now let's look at
what is the problem in case of beta
oxidation which oxidation takes place in
the mitochondria but in order to start
with the oxidation process the raw
material that means the fatty acid need
to enter the mitochondria but the
problem means the long-chain fatty acids
such as per meet week and permitting
acid cannot cross the mitochondrial
membrane as the membranes are
impermeable to long-chain fatty acids in
this situation a shuttle system is
required and that is all about the
Curnutt in shuttle system car native
shuttle system is comprised of two major
components current in permit will
transfer is one CP t1 or and the current
in permit will transfer is to see bt 2
and the third component is very
important which is a translocation Plex
and its function we would learn in a
moment so first this is carnitine
carnitine is a carrier molecule you can
think about it so first of all the amino
acid would be combined with turnitin to
form Parma to Eternity and this reaction
would be carried out by the help of
carnitine vomit oil transfer s1 or CPT
one enzyme after that permit will Condon
would be transported into the
mitochondrial matrix via the
translocates channel liberated the inner
membrane once it is in the matrix the CP
t2 enzyme would convert the puppy to
carnitine into free carnitine and
Parmesan Kui the parameter will coil now
could be used to generate acetyl cool
and the current regime would be shuttled
back into the cytoplasm where it can
perform a next round of transport that
is how the carnitine shuttle system is
very important in context of fatty acid
breakdown and it is a prerequisite of
fatty acid breakdown now in case of
failed state the body would try not to
degrade fatty acid in this situation
there is no need of breaking down fatty
acid because already there is plenty of
energy coming from glucose so in this
situation body has to stop or stop the
probability that fatty acid oxidation
would take place now at the same
situation body has to make fatty acids
and store it into the animal's tissue so
in the libre put aside fatty acid
biosynthesis is favored and the key
molecule there is important for fatty
acid biosynthesis is Mel royal cooing
merrily turned out to be an inhibitor of
CPT one now CPT one is actually
inhibited by Melanie way when Mel Mel
who is converted into acetyl equal eight
and that particular pathway is triggered
by acetyl Kuwait transfer it acetyl co a
carboxyl is enzyme this carboxyl is
enzyme carboxylate acetyl co a to form a
line cooling now insulin triggers the
activity of acetyl co a
Boxey means and insulin is only present
in the fed state not in the fasted State
thereby we can understand the role of
insulin in the regulation of fed state
versus fasted state because in that
failed state insulin would activate the
acetyl co a carboxylic enzyme as a
result acetyl co a would be converted
into meryl cooing melanin would one side
prevent the activity of carnitine permit
will transfer is 1 or CPT 1 and on the
other hand side manual cooling would be
channeled into fatty acid biosynthesis
pathway this is the importance of the
carnitine shuttle system in context of
fatty acid anabolism and catabolism and
we also understood that how insulin and
many other hormones can regulate this
shuttle system depending upon the demand
in order to meet the physiological
context so I hope this video was useful
if you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe do let me know in the comment
how you like my video thank you